era da veramente un secolo che non
faceva un blog proprio puro di euro oggi
per a tutti i ragazzi sono bravi j è
venuti a questo nuovo video io sono
famiglie e benvenuti suo video è
successa una cosa è veramente bizzarra
ve la racconto perché ieri una tipa una
mia fan so ma mi scrive su instagram ma
da un direct mi ha scritto la seguente
cose adesso ve la faccio vedere per
questa casa fan si chiama giada e mi ha
scritto in direct già da sei una gran
[ __ ] e io non capivo perché noi siamo
dati un direct del genere poi ho capito
la genialità di questa ragazza
ovviamente lei ha scritto sta roba per
poter poi uscire dalla conversazione e
screenare l'anteprima perché
nell'anteprima da lei ne compare il mio
nome
quindi parigi con la scritta gialla e
una grafica quindi sembra che il rustico
io in realtà è stata lei a scriverlo
screenare poi alle mandarlo alle amiche
è una roba che non ha senso però era
geniale generalmente non c'ho mai
pensato la roba del genere allora ho
fatto un test ho detto le scriviamo a
selena gomez
la stessa identica cosa c'è nel senso ho
scritto messaggio un po più plausibile
non tipo favi chiese un gran figo parte
che lei in inglese avrebbe senso e il
messaggio che lo scritto è stato your
soul of lei che significa non lo so cosa
significa però è una frase del genere in
inglese assolto la chat o fatto segnare
come non letta mi sembra proprio che me
lo abbia scritto lei perché è nato il
mio direct e l'ho pubblicato nelle mie
storie di quello giuro
pensavo che nessuno cascasse a questa
cagata veramente ma è una cagata è una
cagata incredibile c'è veramente lo può
fare chiunque
nessuno ha pensato al fake tutti pensa a
tutti ma tutti hanno pensato fosse una
cosa reale o screenato pubblicato il
direct scrivendo in che senso
quindi sembra come la bizkit olè ma è
una cagata genere è veramente si capisce
lontano un chilometro che fake ma come
può scrivermi selena gomez st manco chi
so ragazzi nessuno ma nessuno ha capito
che la fake
tutti pensano che sia vero tutti quindi
ragazzi adesso vi faccio vedere un paio
di messaggi di amici ma proprio amici
miei che mi hanno risposto giusto per
farvi due risate
primo messaggio shock e despar attentati
o dio il tuo sogno da anni si parla di
gente over 20 a 20 anni e quindi un po
più smart no il primo passo è fatto
grande rendici orgogliosi
sto sclerando io per te porca miseria
scherzi ma perché non risponde a me sono
gelosa ma perché risponde sono i più
belli ma quando sul matrimonio già
immagino la scritta costumers non avevo
dubbi weight watch davvero mi sono
arrivate marchi si sono seguiti gli
amici non dei fan surina mao ma lo sai
che facciamo i goals and click bateman
poi c'è ma dai cieli mi ha scritto dal
giappone sarei jetlag ato su rai perché
non ci credo che ci dica skull pure tu
che fai cose del genere pure suo ricerca
specie è proprio andata da dio ma che
l'ha scritto ma non è vero oppure no a
sori è vero
attenzione fermi tutti abbiamo un
vincitore questo facciamo vedere fa vj
mai happiness magari tu hai usato il
trucchetto dinstein l'unica perso
l'unica persona che finora se n'è
accorta meritino like meriti veramente
di e trento di serial non meriti il mio
like l'avresti meritato sono prestato
per quelle la risposta migliore è stata
quella di un mio amico che sua sa che mi
ha scritto sono l'olio super numero 1
d'italia che da un pò lei risponde ai
quesiti prego si sarebbe stato decisivo
comunque frank improvvisato finito bene
secondo pubblicato la storia ho detto
vabbè facciamo tempo un secondo
mischiavano tutti e invece no e stato
divertente finché dura la tua selena se
guardi questo video
sappi che c'è possibilità si sa mai era
un frank e mi dispiace per chi ci ha
creduto sul serio era un frank ma non
era un brand non pensavo facesse così
tanto scalpore però è stato figo come
lava la vostra settimana amici miei non
so se vi ricordate l'insetto quello
gigante che 2 anno un anno e mezzo fa
più o meno ha invaso casa mia è
quell'insetto non l'ho più visto grazie
a dio però è successa una roba molto
analoga durante la settimana ciao per
addormentarmi erano le due di notte ho
deciso di rimanere sveglio fino alle 2
di notte perché dovevo finire di vedere
un film su netflix non succede ma io
adesso come i vecchi all'una tipo scenda
la bava
vero per carità però mi addormento per
luna mi addormento sempre mi sono
sforzato di rimanere sveglio perché
dovevo vedere un film su netflix o
finito il film erano le 2 faccio per
andare a dormire e mi vedo sulle coperte
perché mi metto le coperte perché ho
paura del buio quindi le coperte mi
proteggono ho avuto una visione
infernale sulle mie coperto visto questo
per questo questo movimento qua di una
mano sarebbe stato più gradevole però
non era una mano ero così alzo la testa
così un mezzo addormentato tra l'altro
ha scelto non capisco cos'è accendo la
luce
non so se avete presente cos'è una
locusta no questa è una faceva schifo
faccia veramente schifo e rai3 è che era
grosso chi era veramente ma veramente
grosso ragazza era grossa così dal video
che state per vedere che ovviamente ho
registrato dal video che state per
vedere non sembra gigantesche
si vede che grossa ma non sembra così
grossa era veramente grossa dal video io
non mi avvicinavo perché poteva saltarmi
in bocca ad un momento all'altro quindi
zoom avo dalla distanza quando zoom i
non si capiscono bene le proporzioni
[Musica]
quindi ragazzi e quest ultima volta che
avete sentito era la morte di quelle di
quell'essere lo spiego perché ero
occupato in combattimento non potevo
resistergli strare con una mano e
combattere con l'altra no perché la cosa
aveva più mani di me ho tirato poi una
botta fortissima ha letto la mancata
perché questa è saltata via tipo goku ed
ha iniziato ad arrampicarsi sul come si
chiama che cos'è la roba che sta usando
lo svizzero mi si è arrampicato solo sui
parquet quilibrio io tentavo poi ha
lanciato lo spiffero casi perché poi si
è messa sotto lo switcher e ho tirato
una botta finale è stato è stato epico
della tipo una di quelle battaglie di
god of war bellissimo meno bello il
mostro ma bella la battaglia spero che
non vi troviate mai delle cose del
genere mai
insomma tutto bene quel che finisce bene
mesi fa tipo un paio di mesi fa 12 mesi
fa stavo in balcone e stavo leggendo sì
ogni tanto leggo anch'io e la notte un
feto vicino al mio tavolino salire una
super perfetta c'è una locusta che non è
giusto
la grossa per enorme non credo siano
dannose però faceva schifo allora mi
sono alzato così mi sono stato così e
sono rientrato in casa e lo lasciate in
balcone ovviamente non l'ho più vista
ovviamente perché come è andata passano
due mesi per a lei la stessa proposta
era grosso così una sveglia che già
hanno come ha fatto entrare era enorme
erano già allora vi faccio capire eroina
balcone l'ho vista e ho detto vabbè sono
all'aria aperta fa schifo quindi entro
però ci sta che una volta nella vita
succeda li vedevano roba leggere dentro
casa no del tuo caso non può esserci un
animale grosso come un cane non può che
lo portava quindi era veramente enorme
non avete idea di quanto fosse groff era
enorme una locusta faceva schifo volo
morire ma guarda
flics stavo guardando io ero disteso li
guardavo lì niente adesso lo guarda lei
va bè abbonamento lo pago io e poi fai
quello che vuoi
quindi ragazzi questa è questo sono
state così successo durante la settimana
selena gomez non si è presentata da
locusta sì speriamo che un giorno di
trovare anche selena gomez che fa però
mai dire mai e per carità guardo lì
perché c'è letto quindi ho paura di
taglio walking 7 ogni tanto ed da decina
avanti dunque dormo sempre da cani
perché vi guardo sempre intorno che non
ci sia niente
la vita fa schifo quindi ragazzi i
propri video vi sia piaciuto spero che
abbiate fatto un buon inizio di scuole
ricordatevi trovate il mio zaino per chi
ancora fosse senza zaino i vari posti di
vendita zaini ma ci sono anche i miei
quaderni il mini portapenne quindi se ce
l'avete sgangherati cambiateli per mio
figlio prossima collezione il metto la
locusta al posto del mio nome per la
collezione locusta dio mio che settimana
va bè ragazzi io spero che video vi sia
piaciuto come al solito se video è
piaciuto lasciato momento non mi piace
anche un rito giacomino data descrizione
ricordatevi che domani domenica dalle
due e mezza alle sette e mezzo sarò in
live come tutte le domeniche
rcd
[Musica]